Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz
Ben bir erkeğim
Evet çünkü bilinen bütün kutsal
metinlerde savaşlarda iç savaşlarda
dinlerde ve evlerde çatışmalarda
adımdan hep İnsanoğlu diye bahsedildi ve
İnsanoğlu bir erkekti
önce Adem geldi
sonra Havva onun kaburgalarından
yaratıldı ve başına işler açmak üzere
çok geriye gittin uzattın diyebilirsiniz
Yok hala bir erkeğim 2011 yılında kadın
ve aileden sorumlu devlet Bakanlığının
adı
Aile ve Sosyal Politikalar Bakanlığı
olarak değiştirildi yani kadının adı
Devletten de silindi
kadın ancak aile içinde var Olabilir Tek
başına bir birey olarak değil
tarih boyunca Kadınlar erkeklerin
boyutlarını iki ya da 3 misli gösteren
çok sihirli ve enfes Aynalar olarak
görev yaptılar ama şimdi artık kadının
aynı olmak değil aynaya bakma Vakti
Geldi Hoş kadının gerçek boyutlarını
gösterebilen bir aynada henüz icat
edilmedi
Benim kadın olduğumu anlamam kadınlık
hallerini anlamam tam 40 yılımı aldı
beyinle kalp arası 40 santim ama benim
aklımda olanı yüreğime indirmem 40 sene
mi aldı
size 41 yaşımdan bildireceğim kronolojik
olarak
başlangıçta ana akım erkek annesi
olacağım
rekabetinden Çok uzakta her gün Tanrıya
kızım olsun diye dua eden bir anne
sonra sadece kız sorun olursa bakarım
şartı koşan bir babaanne
başından iki evlilik geçmiş gönlünün
istediğini seçmiş Belki o gün itibariyle
adını feminist olduğunu bilmeyen ama
gerçek bir feminist şahane bir kadın
sonra 5 yaşında
Uslu Muslu cici bici bir kız Zaten
başımıza ne geliyorsa bu Uslu Kız
olmaktan geliyor benim de başıma bir
tekme ve yumruk geldi
başımın üzerinden atlıyordu atlayacaktı
Güya uzun eşek oynuyorduk anaokulunda
ama başıma atlamakmış muradı beni
radyatörün peteklerine sokmak suretiyle
başımı yerdi 5 yaş itibariyle ve sonra
sorulduğunda ben onu beğeniyordum
dikkatini çekmek istedim demiş
5 yaş itibariyle Bir erkek bir kızı
seviyorsa beğeniyorsa başını yarar gibi
bir çıkarsa da bulundum
hem hep çok Kısaydı daha gür çıksın diye
annem kısa kestirirdi hep oğlunuz ne de
yakışıklı falan derdi annemin
arkadaşları sonra ilk çıkma teklifimi
bir kızdan aldım şöyle gerçekleşti olay
genelde erkeklerle oynuyorum kaykaya
biniyorum falan
Sonra bir kız geldi bir gün 10
yaşındayım
Dondurma yiyelim mi dedi Yaşasın dedim
hani kızlar gruplarını alacaklar kız
arkadaşlarım da olacak falan dondurma
yemeye gittik dondurmacı amca beni
tanıyor
Ece nasıl istersin dondurmanın dedi
yanındaki kız senin adın Ecrin mi Dedi
Evet Dedi
Ece kız ismi dedi Bir kaçışı var
arkasında bile bakmadan
Demek ki Hakikaten ben de flört etmek
için hani o dondurma yemeye gidelim
demiş Sonra şey kafayı yordum bu
toplumsal cinsiyet rollerinin üzerimize
geçirdiği deli gömleğine Yani
kısa saç diye bir şey yok erkek saçı
diye bir şey var Eğer bir kızın saçı
kısaysa o erkektir falan veya pembe
kızlar pembe Giyer Kızlar niye pembe
giysin sonra büyüdüklerinde bir
bakıyorlar hayat toz pembe bir şey değil
bu kadar kırılgan ve duygusal bir şey
değil veya kızlar işte bebeklerle oynar
falan
Yoo belki helikopterle oynamak istiyorum
belki uçakla belki dünyanın en iyi
pilotu olacak bir tane karikatür vardı
anneden karar verdim oto tamircisi
olacağım diyor annesi de ama o erkek işi
yavrum diyor ben karar verdiğimden beri
değil anne diyor İşte benim kızım diyor
biz karar verdiğimizden beri değil
Aslında Ortaokulda Koç lisesi'ndeyken
emit Summer night kulübündeydim
Shakespeare'in bir yaz gecesi rüyasında
hipolite canlandırdım yani Amazon
kraliçesine
savaşçı Amazon kraliçesi o zaman
araştırdım Tabii biraz Eski Türkler
Amazon Aslında ve o güne kadar hep
Turgut Uyar'ın da dediği gibi işte
birini kurbağa öper biri yedi cüce ile
yaşar biri asırlarca uyur
biri kuleye kilitlenir bir masal
prensesi olsam bile kadınlık zordur diye
o güne kadar hep onlarla yani işte
sindirella'lar uyuyan güzeller kül
kedileri pamuk prenseslerle büyümüşüm
yani sadece kaderine boyun eğen değil
yani Beyaz Atlı prensini bekleyen ve
kaderine boyun eğen diye baya Çilekeş
kadınlar kraliçe olmak için bu kadar
çile çekmesi gereken ve pasif sonra bir
anda Amazon kraliçesi hayatıma yeni bir
bakış açısı getirdi
sonra CNN Türk'te
muhabirlik yaparken en zor meslek
işsizlik diye bir belgesel çektim
birçok ile gittim Özellikle kadın
intiharlarının çok olduğu illere Doğu
illeri
gittim ve şunu gördüm Aslında kadınların
intihar etmiyor babaları dayıları erkek
kardeşleri dedeleri tarafından tecavüze
uğruyor ve sonra
namusumuz kirlendi diyerek
öldürüyorlar infaz ediyorlar
ve bu ustalıkla üstü kapanan bir mesele
Çünkü Anneler de susuyor neden susuyor
evin direği erkek evin ekonomisi erkek
üzerinden dönüyor
kız çocuk gözden çıkarılabilir Ama evin
erkeğini kaybedemeyiz
sonrasında
hamile kaldım ve 5 aylığa kadar Güneş
cinsiyetini göstermedi
o gün ultrasona gideceğiz O gün artık
gösterecek diye böyle çok meraktayım
Kız Evlat mı geliyor erkek mi uyku
tutmadı sabah yürüyüşe çıktım
sahil yolunda yürüyorum hepimizin
kadınlar olarak görünmez dikiz
aynalarımız vardır hani Takip ediliyor
muyum Aman biri beni arkamdan takip
ediyorum falan diye o görünmez dikizam
aynı ama birisi takıldı genç bir erkek
takip ediyor beni Ben de 5 aylık
hamileyim önce saat kaç diye sordu saati
söyledim sonra fotoğrafımı çekebilir
misiniz dedi fotoğrafını çekerken şöyle
bir süzdüm transparan bir tayt giymişti
gözlerinde sürmeler vardı
Saçları çok değişik bir kesimdi Feminen
bir görüntüsü vardı
belki cinsel yönelimi eş cinsellik biraz
yürüyebilir miyiz abla dedi yürüyelim
Tabii dedim kendinden bahsetti O
yürüyüşte bana ben dedi bir aşiret
çocuğuyum
üçüncü erkek çocuğuyum ailenin annem ben
erkek doğuyum diye her gün hamileliğin
her günü dua etmiş ve yatmış
hamileliği boyunca yatmış Evet ben erkek
doğdum ama kendimi erkek gibi
hissetmiyorum dedi ameliyat parasını da
biriktirdim
ama Ameliyat olursa abilerim beni
yaşatmaz film gibi yani
bir saat ya da bir saat 15 dakika
boyunca yürüdük birlikte biraz kendimce
onu rahatlatmaya çalıştım neler
yapabileceğini yönelik bir takım
alternatifler sunulup falan rahatlamış
ayrıldı O gün ultrasonda Güneş
cinsiyetini gösterdi fakat Sonra şuna
kafa yordum
kadın tanımını yaparken Belki de erkeği
de yeniden tanımlamamız gerekiyor Yani
kadına özgürleştirmenin yolu erkeği de
özgürleştirmekten geçiyor sadece cinsel
yöneliminin eşcinsellik olması
gerekmiyor Bir erkeği çok sert bir
erkeklik kafesine hapsetmiyor muyuz
Erkekler Ağlamaz erkekler köpekten
Korkmaz
erkeklerin canı acımaz erkeklere eve
ekmek getirir erkekler evi geçindirir
erkekler hesabı öder
bu şekilde
belki kadınları bu cinsiyet
ayrımcılığında haklarından mahrum
ediyoruz ama erkekleri de
insanlıklarından mahrum ediyoruz gibi
geliyor
acaba Türkiye'de kaç erkek böyle sert
küçük bir erkeklik kafesini
hapsedilmiştir ve bu bunun sonucu ne
olmuştur yani ağlamasına izin verilmeyen
acı çekmesine izin verilmeyen bir birey
insan olabilir mi
ondan empati kurmasını şefkatli olmasını
bekleyebilir miyiz
normal doğum yapmak istedim Güneş de
öyle istedi bu biliyorsunuz takım
organizasyonu birlikte işte güneşle bu
işi becereceğiz ve ben normalde doğum
yapacağım büyük bir sancı çekiyorum
eşimin annesi geldi Sürmeli bir kapı var
benim doğum yapacağım yani yattığım
odayla misafirlerin ağırlandığı oda
arasında Sürmeli kapıyı kapattı
ve ben çok sancı çekiyorum
üzülmüyorsun değil mi dedi
üzülüyorum biraz sancım var Evet yok yok
onu kastetmedim dedi
ne için bizim oralarda kız çocuk
doğurmak biraz
biraz şey ne
biraz şey ney
Sessizlik oldu kız doğdu Hani iğrenç bir
laf var ya Sessizlik oldu ve kızlı oldu
hakikaten Sessizlik oldu ve Kızım doğdu
orada şunu düşündüm bir kere
bir apolet bir rütbe olarak erkek annesi
olmak bir toplumsal statü olarak
ve kadının
mevcut durumunu konumunu kabullenişi bu
şekliyle sorgulama işi sonra
bir
toksik erkek modeline doğuran böyle bir
annelik anlayışı Yani o erkek o evde bir
sırf erkek olduğu için bir Prens gibi
bir kral gibi ağırlanıyorsa hiç hak
edilmemiş bir imtiyaz sahibi oluyorsa
her vurduğunu deviriyorsa kırıyorsa
bir naylon iktidara sahip oluyorsa
sonrasında yine O insandan insanlık
bekleyebilir miyiz Yani
var olmayı sahip olmak
kudreti kırmak parçalamak olarak
algılayan
Diğer erkek sonra Ya Benimsin Ya
toprağım modelini doğurmuyor mu
sonra Show Haber'de Ya Benimsin Ya
Toprağın cinayetleri uzak ve güvenli bir
mesafeden sunuyorum Ama şunu görüyorum
katillerin %40'ı koca yüzde onu eski
koca
evlenebileceğiniz diye boşanabileceğiniz
birini bulun benden size tavsiye
Evet yani 1934'te Atatürk sayesinde
birçok Medeni ülkeden önce seçme ve
seçilme hakkını kazanmış olan kadın
yaşam hakkını seçemiyor
kadın Eylül üstünde tutmaktan
anladığımız tabutuna omuz vermek oluyor
rakamlar korkunç
Olağanüstü hal ilan etmelik Yani bir
kadın kırımı var Türkiye'de soykırım
gibi bir şey kadın mı Ama Olağanüstü hal
ilan edileceği yerde konuyla ilgili
olarak bir takım elbise şık bir kravat
beyaz bir gömlekle her an olağanüstüler
iyi hale dönüştürülebiliyor
suç
un ceza görmeyeceğine güvenen bir
canavarlığa dönüşebildiğini gördüm
cezasızlığın büyük bir azmettirici
olduğunu ve
kurbanla değil katille empati Kuran bir
anlayış olduğunu Yani Şule Çetin o
saatte plazada ne işi vardı özgecan'ın
minibüste ne işi vardı
Pınar'ın bağ evinde ne işi vardı dediğim
gibi katil lempati Kuran kurbanla değil
Sonra işte bir elektrik direği örneği
haber merkezlerine bir haber geldi bizim
haber merkezimize Show tv'deyken Adamın
biri elektrik direğine tecavüz ediyor
dedim ki Hadi bakalım Bunu buna bir
uyarlayalım Hani onun orada ne işi vardı
Bunun burada ne işi vardı elektrik
direğinin o saatte o sokakta ne işi
vardı
niye bu kadar ışık saçıyordu parlaktı
tecavüz sırasında adama elektrik
çarpmadığına göre elektrik direğine
rızası mı vardı
veya kısasa kısasa olsaydı
şimdi durumun abi sürttüğünü anlatacak
bir örnek ama sonra suçun bulaşıcılığını
gördüm suç bulaşıcı yani Emine Bulut
kızının önünde boğazı kesilerek
öldürüldükten sonra birçok kadın kocası
tarafından boğazı kesilerek öldürülmeye
başlandı ve kadınlar şunu demeye
başladılar öldürülmekten korkmuyorum
sadece çocuğumun önünde Ve boğazım
kesilerek olmasın
düşünebiliyor musunuz dedim ki buraya
kadar yargı dağıtan abladan artık Yardım
dağıtan ablaya geçmenin vakti geldi
ben gideceğim ve kadınlar için bir
şeyler yapacağım yani adaletin daha
hızlı tecelli etmesi için bir şeyler
yapacağım Susmaya geçtim orada
olay çok kişiselleşti plazada ne işi
vardı dediğimiz Şule Çetin Hayatta en
sevdiği şeyin yazları babasıyla
Giresun'da fındık toplamak olduğunu
öğrendim
Emine Bulut'un yeniden üniversite
okuduğunu çok güçlü bir akrep kadını
olduğunu Kasımda
çok güçlü olduğunu
ama sırf abileri hapse Fedai Baran
denilen o cani o mal kestim demişti ya
hayvan kestim taksiye bindiğinde
onu Toprağın altına abilerini hapse
göndermemek için abilerine hiç şikayet
etmemiş Fedai Baran'ın ruhu incinmesin
diye Babası hep dolabı doldururmuş ezik
hissetmesin kendini hep dolapta yiyecek
bir şeyler olsun diye Sonra abileri şunu
dedi adaletimizi kendimiz mi sağlayalım
abla
sonra
İstanbul'un göbeğinde kaçırılan Topal
107 gün sonra kızına
oğluna evladına kavuşan
[Müzik]
potansiyel katilinin adını kanıyla yazan
Nurtaç Canan hepsi ile yüz yüze göz göze
baktık göz göze baktığın anda ahlak ve
vicdan başlıyor Tabii ve son olarak
yağmurun yağmurun için annesi sevgi anne
hayatımı değiştirdi bir milattır benim
için geldi bugün dedim bu yağmur yağdı
mahkemeye kızının adı Yağmur Altı
senedir Adalet gelmiyor ben de adalet
gelecek zannettim gelmedi dedi
adaletin gelmesini bekliyor Yağmur'un
önce turizmden mezun olmasına 2 ay kala
erkek arkadaşı tarafından pompalı
tüfekle öldürülmüş
doğduğunda 52 santimdi Dedi Annesi öyle
gösterdi pompalı tüfekle 52 santimden
vuruldu
evladının yüreği kaç gram biliyor musun
dedi
çok duygusal bir konuşma yapıyor
zannettim o kadar paramparça olmuş ki
evladı gerçekten kızının yüreği kaç gram
biliyor
fakat kendimi görünmez hissediyorum dedi
çünkü geçen gün garson geldi dedi
siparişi almak için adalet olmadığı için
kendimi görünmez hissediyorum garson
üstüme alınmadım hanımefendi ne
istiyorsunuz diye sormuş Hiç üstüne
alınmamış görülme hissediyorum ya sıvı
bile tutamıyorum çünkü Adalet yerini
bulmadı
sonra program bitti ben çok ağır bir
Depresyona girdim
dünyanın sonu insanın yüreğinin içinde
gelir dedikleri türden ağır bir
depresyon acı üzerime birikmiş
ve
Ben atlettim ortaokul lisede maraton
koşanlar bilir bir duvara toslama
olayı vardır mukavemet sporlarında
genelde böyle 30 40 kilometrede
maratonlarda bir anda yere yığılan
Sporcular görürsünüz Çünkü kaslar
ve karaciğer bir anda glikojeni tüketir
ve olduğun yer nereyi yere yığılırsın
artık takatim kalmaz ilerlemeye bende de
40 yaş tam bir duvara toslama yaşı oldu
Sonra bir gün
yazlıktayız aylarca süren bir depresyon
Sürekli uyuma hali falan
yazlıkta güneşin uyandığı odaya güneş
doğuyor Güneş kızımın adı Kızım Nerede
yok şu anda dışa tavşanlarla oynuyor
Tamam ve
güneşin gözüne girmesin diye hep perdeyi
kapatıyorum
o gün beş buçuk altı gibi uyandı anne
Perdeyi aç Güneş girsin dedi ama kendi
içindeki perdeyi de aç dedi
6 yaşında bir çocuğum böyle bir cümle
kurması zaten başlı başına haber değeri
taşıyor onu Ayrıca konuşuruz
kendi içindeki perdeyi açtım onun ricası
üzerine doğum günümde ya da bir gün
önceydi ya 20 Temmuz ya 21 Temmuz bu yaz
ve şunu gördüm bir
bir kadınım bir kadının kaç defa
küllerinden doğar Yani bir ömre kaç tane
Hayat sığdırır ben
800 metre koşarken bir gün ısınırken
çivilileriyle başka bir arkadaşım elime
bastı 800 metreyi böyle elimden kanlar
akarak falan Koştum ve İkinci oldum
Buğra Felekle sonra annemle babam
boşanmaya gittiğinde o günlerde işte
üniversite sınavına girdim ve iyi bir
üniversiteyi kazandım sonra
kariyerime sıfırdan başlamak zorunda
kaldım birilerini mobil yüzünden 6 sene
sonra 6 sene diploması ve ekonomi
muhabirliği yaptıktan sonra
arı vız vız vız diye Kızım o oynatırken
bir anda savaşın içine gittim
akçakale'ye Barış bunları harekatında
yan sokağıma roketatar mermisi düştü
PKK bizim yayın yaptığımız yerin
koordinatlarını birbiriyle paylaştı yani
son anda kurtulduk günlerce orada
savaşta kaldım
Ben birkaç kere küllerimden doğmuşum onu
fark ettim sonra güneşe baktım benim
kızım
rapunzellerle kül kedileriyle falan
büyümüyor benim kızım moanalarla Bra
evlerle elsalarla raylarla yani sadece
beyaz atlı prensini beklemeyen kendi
kaderini kendi yazan değil ülkesinin
kaderini dünyanın kaderini yeniden yazan
savaşçı kadınlarla büyüyor
sonra kim olduğumu hatırladım Türklerin
en eski yarış feminizmdir biliyorsunuz
yani kadına zordu kadın çok iyi at
biniyordu silahşördü hükümdardı kalem
muhafızıydı
ve sonrasında Kurtuluş Savaşı'nda cephe
önünde ve gerisinde erkeklerle Omuz
Omuza savaşan kadınlar Halide Edip
adıvarlar bütün ekonomiyi döndüren
kadınlar
1789 Fransız devriminde kadın erkekle
eşit haklarla doğar ve eşit haklarla
Yaşar bir kadını Eğer sen idam sehpasına
çıkartıyorsan konuşma kürsüsüne de
çıkartacaksın diyen
Rosa parks örneği Ne bileyim 1936'da ilk
kadın Savaş pilotu Sabiha Gökçen
sonra Marie curisi artık dünyanın Özlem
türeci nasa'da bir kadınımız var Türk
kadını Feryal özel
kim olduğumu hatırladım Polonyalı
kadınlar kürtaj hakları için meydana
inen Ondan sonra
siyahi kadınlar sonra bu lastiği
biliyorsunuz
küresel tecavüze karşı marş besleyen
Şileli kadınlar dans edemeyeceksek bu
bizim devrimimiz değildir ve bulunanlı
kadınlar talibana karşı gelen Afgan
kadınlar ve son olarak
kuş ölürsen uçuşu hatırla diyen İranlı
şairi fehru uzatır şiirindeki gibi
ölen ama ölürlerken bize uçuşu ve
özgürlüğü hatırlatan İranlı kadınlar
bugün protestoların ellinci gününde
yürekleri ve saçları rüzgarlarla Özgür
hepsini kadın böyle bir şey işte kadın
bitmek bilmeyen bir güç küllerinden
doğma hali cesaret Yürek dayanıklılık
sonra
kadın doğulmaz kadın olunur
kadın olunur kadınlık hakkımız söke söke
alırız Peki nasıl sökeceğiz soru bu
dünyadaki bütün eşitsizliklerin altında
Ataerkil bir düzen yatıyor
ırkçılık
kapitalizm
ataerkillik hepsi küresel o zaman kadın
mücadelesinde küresel olması gerekiyor
birbirimizden farklılıklarımız olabilir
ama bunlara rağmen birlikte mücadele
ederek Çünkü dünyadaki farklılıklarına
rağmen en güçlü küresel hareket
ataerkillik işte bizim de bugün
zincirlerimizi kırma Vaktimiz geldi
zincirlerimizden Başka kaybetecek
neyimiz var şimdi değilse
ne zaman dünyada görmek istediğimiz
değişikliğin
bizzat kendisi olalım
zincirlerimizi kıralım bu mücadeleyi
elele kol kola beraber verilmiş Şimdi ve
burada
[Alkış]